okay uh so Rachel is going to tell us
about new ways to Marvel or athletic
circuits
all right
I am going to tell you about how to
level arithmetic circuits and this is
joined to work with
my students
martial law
uh fabulous sitting there carrying a
little who is right now in China
so let's do it
so we are all very familiar with double
circuits this is really probably every
cryptographer knows we this is a tool
that enables us to convert
circuit
into your Boolean circuit into a gobbled
format together with
a pair of keys for each wire I call aibi
for the input wire I
and the guarantee is that
given one of the label for each of the
input wire where which is chosen
according to the input you want to
evaluate on so and if x i is 1 you
choose AI if x y is zero you choose bi
given the double circuit together with
the input levels we can get the output
the nice thing is that that's the only
thing one can get okay and this is a
formulated by saying that in this case
I'm going to consider a notion of hiding
where we don't care about hiding the
circuit but we only care about hiding
the input but you can of course also
talk about hiding the circuit then there
is a simulator that given the circuit
and the output which we are willing to
reveal is able to simulate everything
sorry this should be L of X is able to
simulate the gobble circuit together
with the input level without knowing the
input at all so anything about the input
beyond the output remains hidden
it is very important that in this
formulation that the input labels are
very short the length of the input label
should be independent of the size of the
circuit right and so this bit lens T is
independent of the circuit size or the
depth or any parameter
and furthermore that another nice
feature is that the input encoding is
actually really really simple that it
looks at each of the input bit x i
one by one independently this is called
the decomposable property and the second
is that it's a very simple computation
based on the input value here it's on
just a selection and you can write it as
a fine function
all right so gobble circuit together
with its Leader by the formulation of
randomized encoding is really the Swiss
army knife for cryptography and if you
look they're just everywhere to the
point that we don't even pay attention
if a paper uses double circuit
they're just really everywhere right
for the citations
the two Key properties that we often
rely on when we use a double circuit is
that first day has really simple
doubling in the sense that the goblin
algorithm has low depths and could even
be local the second is that it has
really simple input encoding that the as
I said the input labels are short they
are decomposable encoding under Alpha
encoding this if we look at all these
applications these are the properties
that we use of the double circuit
what about techniques what do we know
about this Swiss army knife how to build
this with army knife
but we have one dominant
method which is the encrypted truth
table method if you have seen it you
probably know that this method is
basically look at each of the gates one
by one and we're going to encrypt the
truth table of the gate
and the promoted now we call it the
encrypted true stable method
has received so many optimizations it's
impossible to list all the citations in
recent years that we're really towards
moving towards the shipping this
encrypted to stable method to the
practice so here when we're talking
about optimizations we're not just
talking about asymptotics we really
actually counting bits and bytes and we
can achieve practical efficiency
and the state of the art in this really
really nice paper by uh Lawrence and
Mike is that instead of having four
Cypher attacks which will be four Lambda
per multiplication or addition gear they
can actually achieve 1.5 cyber text to
forget
really mysterious but
but it's the level we care about the
concrete constants from four down to 1.5
what are the other techniques well based
on the double circuit this technique we
can build a gamble Turing motion or Ram
okay
and if we added hit it with IO or
functional encryption
then we can even get a succinct version
of the gobble run
and the other method well there's a work
that
achieves the reusability which says that
I can actually double the circuit once
and then keep reusing it with different
input encodings and all of the input
encodings are short independent of the
circuit complexity
and this technique is in some sense
debating the most away from the
encrypted truth table method so far it
really relies crucially on for the home
of encryption attribute based encryption
but they still use this double circuit
as a component
Okay so basically so far there's no
doubt that the encrypted truth table is
still the most widely used method in
Goblin invented in the 80s and we're
still using it day by day
so the question is can we do it
differently
and to explore can we do it differently
I'm going to explore a slight variant of
this problem which was proposed by
whenever
and yeah
it has to be an aik right sorry it
should be aik 11. and uh here they
propose why don't we look at arithmetic
circuits and try to gobble that
whatever is my circuit now our circuits
that contains every smarty Gates
additional multiplication Gates
and they do arise pretty naturally for
example in scientific confusion
computation in machine learning in
crypto systems
and for different applications that we
might care about different on the lying
ring we do those arithmetic operations
we're going to primary focus in this
talk the Ring of the integers integer
computation and the Ring of zp
for any modular speed but you could
really consider anything right you can
consider the polynomial ring as well or
anything else
so there is a baseline solution when we
look at arithmetic Circle which is well
we can always convert it first into a
Boolean one and just apply the encrypted
truth table method that we love and I
know
however to delay from encryption
encrypted Tuesday but I want to ask or
aik asked can we download every smarter
circuit without bullionizing the
computation
okay
and why well there are multiple reasons
sometimes the beta composition could be
very expensive and it could be actually
impossible to do in certain settings
for more
what motivates me is that it will kind
of force us to give it from the
encrypted to stable method because the
ring may be exponentially sized the wire
value could be from an exponentially
large domain it is impossible to
enumerate the truth table of the gate
and by doing so we might in a very
unexpected way arrive nevertheless at
those goals like efficiency and
modularity that we care about but in a
completely different route
okay
so what do we know about Goblin
arithmetic circuits the aik work give
the first Construction
oh so forgot about that so far I haven't
told you what's the definition
so let's go is the definition first
very similarly we want to have an
adopting algorithm that converts an
arithmetic circuit into the double
format but now the input labels are not
the pairs of keys but rather a fine
function
right these are five functions are still
defined by two keys but those two keys
are now coefficient okay
and the input label for a particular
ring element x i is a i x i plus bi
evaluated in the ring
okay and those functions may actually
the coefficients themselves may be a
vector so that's why an x i is a scalar
and that's why the label itself is a
vector in the ring
now the rest is the same given those
labels input label and the double
circuit I want to compute the output and
reveal only the output
same we want all the nice properties
that we love we write on from double
circuit to hold we would like the goblin
algorithm to be
shallow we would like
the input labels to be short independent
of the circuit complexity and we already
have the decomposability and a fine
encoding in this formulation
well if we think about that this indeed
Force us to do something different from
Boolean Goblin because I have to treat
these input elements as ring elements
right
however
this definition itself does not really
exclude the goblin method internally
tries to do some big decomposition of
the Ring elements and arrive at actually
bits and use the same kind of Boolean
gambling afterwards
so therefore for my purpose of debating
from ingredients table
I'm going to care about an additional
property this additional property is
that my gobbling and evaluation
algorithm should both be Black Box in
the implementation of the arithmetic
operations over the ring
never use the code
the circuit that implements the
additional multiplication
this is a way for me asking for this
property is a way to enforce us to not
try to bullionize intermediate values
and the arithmetic operations yeah
the specific Ring The Ring is still
going to be specifically indeed in this
case the better case you would want to
have is a construction that is fully
fully black boxing the ring not just
black box in the addition multiplication
implementation but also in the ring
elements representation and only use
very small interface from The Ring this
would be a fully buy box implementation
and in that case one would with one
construction automatically gets
arithmetic Goblin for every possible
ring and now the indeed to be really
really nice unfortunately this stream
was crushed and a previous work showed
that this is impossible to do hence you
need to have some access to the ring but
the number that nevertheless for my
purpose of dominating from the encrypted
juice table it's enough for me to only
ask for not using the code of additional
multiplication
all right so chemical definition what do
we know how to what do we know about the
goblin hours by the circuit not that
much aik showed that assume lwe there is
an arithmetic Goblin scheme for founded
integer computation so there are
considering an underlying ring that is
over the integers
and furthermore if I consider integer
computation the value grows like doubly
exponentially with the depth of the
computation so it's in order for
everything to be efficient they put this
constrain that this is integer
computation but has the guarantee that
or the wire values is bounded by a
priori bound B okay
and they actually give another
construction which basically says what I
mentioned already before the goblin
algorithmetry is going to use the
Chinese remainder theorem to implicitly
explicitly do bit decomposition inside
and afterwards apply yells gobble
circuit as a result it doesn't satisfy
the property of being non beam Black Box
in additional multiplication I think and
I won't compare with this Construction
in the rest of the talk I will mostly
compared with the first one which is
more truly arithmetic
all right so what are our results
we tackle three different models the
first is the same as aik founded integer
computation the second we managed to do
zp computation the third we consider a
mixed computation where your circuit can
have both bounded integer operation and
the Boolean operation
in order of those models we give
construction based on both rwe and the
Parlier and the perlier is a new
assumption that is
that makes this talk fitter purpose of
this Workshop
I feel kind of
weird because everybody has been so
harmonious talking about this abstract
and like you know and I'm I'm showing
you like concrete constants
all right so
diversifying the assumption
founded into computation significantly
improve the efficiency this Goblin
actually has constant rate that I am
going to Define constantly very soon
our zp computation is
Black Box in the additional
multiplication satisfy the special
property I asked for and finally the
mixed integer computation is providing a
more flexible model where I think a lot
of natural applications fits within if
you think about
deep neural networks and it is also more
efficient
alright so more formally what is the
rate of the government that I've been
talking about by rate what I mean is
that the size of the double circuit
together with the input encoding
in comparison with the size of the
circuit the number of gates in the
circuit description times L what is l l
is the bits number of bits needed to
represent the elements in the ring okay
so in Napoleon computation L is one in
the B bounded in digital computation L
is log B in the P conversation always
log p so what is this quantity c times L
is basically the size of the computation
Tableau if you were to write down all
the values that have been evaluated in
the competition so we feel it is a fair
to compare the size of a goblin together
with the computation Tableau size in the
clear
so
don't you also want to take into account
the bit size that you need to write
everything yes it is counting it it
counts the best size of writing array
elements
I'm talking about
I I am talking about so if there's a so
C hat you're talking about number of
bits yeah see so in C I talk about
number of gates yeah yeah
to evaluate if you wouldn't grow so what
L sub X that's like the input that's the
lens on the internet yeah
sorry I want to go back
to the number of gates
yeah there's just yeah it's the
description lens
as I think about double circuit what
would be C hat in double circuit it's
gonna be the number of wooden gates
times those doubled Gates
like each double gate is roughly Lambda
size so the C hand size is the c times
Lambda
it will be the same in our case but uh
so we really count the big length of the
square means he had
to give yourself
can you maybe say again white makes
sense to have L like what
there are situations where for example
for nc1 you have arithmetic Goblin where
the C hat is empty
there's simply no double bed at all but
then the length of the label is going to
depend on the denominator
yeah like because it seems like the
right rate is you're encoding something
right they could just send you C itself
when it would have cost me you know
Capital it would cost me absolutely not
absolutely
[Applause]
you could do that also but I feel that
it is so if you really you can
definitely have such a definition and
then everything is just gonna read is
going to be multiplied without
um but the comparison is gonna be the
same between different methods I feel
it's kind of fair to compare the size of
the doubling with the the total length
of writing down your computation table
in the clear
um but yeah you can also consider
differences
you'd want to compare two things right
one is that I'm just going to send you
the circuit and then the input and you
are computed by yourself and the other
one is then going to send you the
cardboard thing and you and again you
will compute by yourself and the array
I don't know I would think would be
the the rate between the uh
maybe it's natural in the context of
existing the factors
okay anyways
is
open for Gateway gate approach
okay so what would be the rate for yeah
take one step back when you talk about C
hat in the arithmetic setup so there she
had because you want to be oblivious
don't see that and see what happens
yeah yeah
no it will not be the same ring
if it's the same ring so we don't know
how to do it yet
okay see how there's some Boolean
circuit you can't even think about it
all right so uh what's the rate of the
Moon and yellow circuit well that really
is basically Lambda as we can see
what's the rate if I applied the
Baseline solution which is I first
convert an arithmetic circuit into a
Boolean one and then apply Yao's Cabo
circuit well basically then every
additional multiplication gauge if I use
in the integer case I use the fastest
asymptotic
um
uh integer multiplication algorithm
which has complexity L Times log l then
we will get this circle size
and we'll get the rate which is Lambda
Times log out
all right so now I can present the first
result which is for bounded integer
Goblin using DCR assumption over partial
group we can get a constant rate when
the size of the integer elements is
roughly the length of the polyure it's
comparable to the lens of the partial
key okay
and this is the first constantly Goblin
for every smartest circuit if you
compare with the baselines it does
improve pretty well compared with Lambda
Factor versus constant Factor
and if you compare with aik scheme then
they have a rate which is the same as
the lwe dimension
actually get down to even sublinear rate
and as your wife is saying however so
far we will only know such schemes using
either IO
or you can use on
the reusable Goblin method which uses
fully homophone encryption however you
will have the caveats that you need to
you only achieve some linear rate if the
tax is sufficiently small
and our result doesn't care about the
depth of the computation at all
sorry for showing you concrete numbers
our numbers also are not too bad
basically we fix the sum setting where
uh the most I'm not going to explain all
the settings but when you do the
calculation for this specific setting
you can actually compute yourself with
the size of a multiplication gate carbon
multiplication game it turns out that
comparing with the state-of-the-art
Boolean Goblin uh we go from the size
which is level of megabyte to the level
of kilobyte so that's roughly 600 to 800
times smaller than the Boolean Baseline
in terms of computation it's less clear
it's roughly a trade-off between one
multiplication mode and where n is the
partier modulus
versus 450 roughly 458 yes calls
so uh I think it does show some
potential for concrete efficiency
however this is not the focus of our
work so definitely worth exploring
okay no more constants all right then we
can handle zp computation we can
directly couple zp computation and the
rate is going to be worse that is going
to be proportional to the key lines of
the DCR or the
LW dimension
on this doesn't compare very well with
the Boolean Baseline asymptotically but
I think that concretely it will probably
be better
so the feature of this one is that we
only make buy box use of additional
multiplication
so you said how like the size of the
circuit scales but like how does the
evaluation time scale
um yeah I don't have the numbers here
it's gonna be very similar to the size
okay because you're doing I'm assuming
you're doing some operations like public
key operation and garbled circuits
usually just like use ads
it's faster practices or something no
that's what I said at the beginning that
it's roughly you compare how many like
um multiplication model versus how many
areas that's two different methods would
use
we're rather than one multiplication
model versus 450 AES cost
but the efficiency is the most obvious
in the bounded integer setting once you
go to VP it's less efficient
so finally let me tell you about this
mixed computation where I think in that
arises pretty naturally in deep neural
net you can think about it that it often
has some fixed point in linear function
first and then it does some num
arithmetic Boolean computation like the
comparison
so we model it as a circuit that
contains arithmetic Gates
founded integers Medicaid and then it
has a big decomposition gauge somewhere
which is going to convert the ring
element into bits and the following that
you can do Boolean computation okay
what can we do is that the overhead for
those arithmetic Gates is the same as
constant
which the composition happens
it's a circuit consisting of any circuit
consisting of those Gates
and the Boolean computation those gates
are going to have an overhead of Lambda
just like in Yao and then in the middle
the basic composition has a heavier
overhead it's kind of quadratic in the
key length of the DCR
all right so another in the remaining
time let me try to how much time do I
have
[Music]
to
us it turns out that when you have the
the labels for bits you can also
interpret the bits as a ring element and
continue computation
okay so let me tell you very quickly
about aik design Paradigm and then in
particular it kind of
decomposes the task into Goblin just
addition the multiplication Gates
separately and then there is a separate
key extension Gadget
and now we'll tell you about another key
extension is the main focus the
difficulty I will tell you about our
idea for key extension and hopefully I
will tell you about the how to handle
the bounded integer
all right so
what is the aikp idea is that if I just
want to double
addition
sorry there should be an addition that's
very easy what we do is that all the
labels are those are fine functions
right evaluation of assigned functions
so if I want to obtain output label with
the p coefficient k0 K1 all what I need
to do is to have input labels with k0
and K1 here and
with the coefficient R and K1 minus r so
if I just add those two labels together
you will get the output label
and this you can interpret it as very
easy to gobble given the coefficient of
the output label function you can create
the label function for the inputs
evaluation just addition and simulation
also extremely simple because this label
one of the label is actually random and
it needs to satisfy the correctness
constraint so given the output label you
just sample one of the label random and
we compute the other label
although I had no multiplication also
extremely simple
what we do is that to have completely
random label for the inputs elements if
you multiply you will get something but
there is lots of cross terms right so
idea is that you provide more labels to
cancel out those cross terms
so evaluation tries to me that this is
gonna work out
and what about simulation well notice
again that all those labels have most
the three of them has completely random
blinding Factor so all it should do is
again you sort of randomly sample those
three and the reverse computes the last
one using output label
so now that I have additional
multiplication why don't I just double
arbitrary circuits
I started with one label and you
normally get two labels yeah
yes so what happens the problem with
conversation is not the label length is
going to explode I started with level of
Dimension T after addition I get the
labels of Dimension T but in order to
get multiplication I need levels of
Dimension protein right and furthermore
for some of the wires which has multiple
fan nodes I even get the labels of
dimension 40. so in other words that the
length of a label in general is going to
be exponential in the depth of the
computation multiplied with the fan out
of the wire
this is not good and that's why only
handles log depth circuit information
theoretically if you think about this is
the same problem in information
theoretic Boolean Goblin okay
so how can we get around this well the
idea is to have something that shrinks
the key down if you think about in
Boolean Goblin the use of the prg is
exactly this purpose
so in this case I want to have a new
Gadget key extension which takes a short
key for input element X and produces a
much longer label for the same element
the formulation is that now the gambling
given the output label function should
give me the input label function which
is much shorter and the sum double table
evaluation should give me
short from the short label expanded to
the long label
and simulation should be able to
simulate the short label and the double
table
now once I have key extension basically
whenever the labels become too long I
just stuck in the the key extension
Gadget to shrink them down to the short
labels
and you can simulate as long as all the
gadgets has its perfect simulation
so the key now is to design this key
extension for any ring if I want
arithmetic Goblin I just want that key
extension in that ring
so let's talk about our ideas in an
abstract term which is easy to
understand and know algebra
suppose I'm just dealing with Boolean
values I'm not doing arithmetic Goblin
I'm doing
Boolean Goblin then the wire value is
just zero one then Q extension is
extremely simple right because I know
that the short label is either a
plus b if x equals to one or it is just
B sorry it should be B
then all what I need to do is to just
sort of like match with the output level
that I should get encrypt them using the
corresponding
key and the output right
and
this is very simple and basically I
don't even need that much of crypto I
just need one time secure secret key
encryption scheme is enough for me right
it's one time secure because the labels
are only used once
the problem now is that on I need to
handle inputs which are not Boolean and
this is in fact basically encrypted to
stable method
so a way to get around this is that what
if my encryption scheme has some nice
arithmetic properties
in particular what if it's linearly
homomorphic
in the sense that there is a way to
operate on the two ciphertext and obtain
a ciphertext which is encrypted using
the sum of the key and the sum of the
input
then what I need to do is in a double
table provide ciphertext that encrypts b
encrypts d using b equal to C using a
given an input
let me show you how we can extend the
label but to do that let's first suppose
that the input is actually public okay
but we'll fix this later because the
wire value is what we want to hide
then all what we need to do is to use
the linear homomorphism property that
we're going to do this homomorphic
evaluation which is multiply the cipher
text with a scalar X
and added together with the second
ciphertext what I should get is
encryption under the short label
and that encrypts a long label
right so how do I evaluate all what I
need to do is to do homomorphic
evaluation using the public wire value X
get this Cipher text no I have the short
label decrypted I will get the long
label right
unfortunately everything looks so good
but what's the problem the problem is
that there are just so many different
Wings going on here right we we have an
underlying computational ring which is R
where the short label and the long label
are sits in the ring
I am pretending that I have an
encryption scheme which has the key
space and the message space both
agreeing the same and they're both the
Ring of my competition
that just never happens unfortunately
and this is in fact the key challenge we
have to tackle
so but let's for now pretend that
everything is fine the key space and the
message space is just my underlying ring
R then how do I see security well
security is basically I want to simulate
using the output label L and I claim
that that the input is public
what do I want to simulate I want to
simulate those table seven vertex one
separate X2
and together with the short label as
well basically I can first to pretend
that it is a basically information
theoretically identical If instead of
sampling cypherd x-172 first and compute
ciphertext in the evaluation I could
actually first to just generate my
output ciphertext
using
some short label I sample myself and the
long label which I want to simulate the
simulator has
and given a cipher text one I can always
recompute ciphertext too subject to the
correctness constraint this is what we
do all the time
now what do we get well as long as my
short label ax plus b actually hides a
which it will we need to make sure that
then subvertex 1 is actually hiding the
key is not revealed anywhere
and hence I can stimulate it randomly
now I arrive at the assimilation right
because the simulation gets along label
L and samples this as itself and
generates the double table in a random
and computed way
all right so everything is so perfect
but what happens oh so far I need to
tell you that how can I make how can I
make the wire value public in fact
that's actually really easy because I
can just modify my online computation
before a key extension is going to
happen I'm going to hide the Y value the
true VAR value X prime using a random
scalar Let It Go through the key
extension and then subtract away this
random scalar so these random scalars
are going to be you can think about as a
constants in the arithmetic Goblin I was
gonna gobble
see you can write out the labels and it
works out
all right so let me now tell you just
give you one taste about
what happens when the message and the
key space is not agreeing with my uh
competition
okay so for that we really don't have
generic Solutions we have to look at the
specific linear homorphic encryption
scheme we are using and come up with a
solution
so one simple then your homographic
encryption we can have is based on the
Parlier groups you don't have to look at
a lot of the specific just know that
polio group elements
contains is kind of a product
of elements in a hard subgroup with
elements in an easy subgroup the harder
subgroup has unknown order and the easy
subgroup has known order
now what does it mean that it is unknown
or it is hard it is because that if I
give you a random hard group element
it's actually indistinguishable from
just a uniform random group element
what does it mean for it to be easy easy
means that if I give you an easy
subgroup element you can actually
discrete log in efficiently
so how do we build a
linear homophone encryptions came out of
it it's basically very similar to Algoma
encryption from ddh you basically run
dth in the hard group
here we have G to the r think about them
as published
and then to encrypt using key a we do G
to the r times a and then we leave the
message we want to encrypt in Easy group
now if you have the key a you can just
raise 2G to the r cancel out the hard
group this will log in the easy group
you will get the message back
well like in the case of ddh this is a
very linearly homomorphic and
furthermore the linear homomorphism is
parallel in the key space in the hard
subgroup and in the easy subgroup right
so if I do just take this ciphertaxis
group element and raise it to X and
multiply with another Cipher text I will
exactly get what I want
an encryption encrypted under ax plus b
for the message of CX plus c
now what's the problem
the message space is some Z into the C
let's pretend for a second that this is
the space we want the same as the ring
computation
but the key space is something really
weird right it is this is a hard group
exponent space and in fact it has
unknown size
I can always pretend that this is just
key space is over the integers right if
I get ax plus b over the integers
clearly I can still decrypt
now the problem is
is I get a short label
in the space of Z and to the C
how do I get the the value over Z back
it turns out that if the computation is
B bounded and that's really simple
because I can always make sure that the
value it means that the value X is
always be bounded and I can choose a and
b in a way that the whole
ax plus b is much smaller than into the
C
right then basically the modulus the
modular arithmetic doesn't take effect
that's what we do in fact the Parlier
key can actually be pretty short
and we just make sure that b is going to
be significantly larger than a times x
so that the short label indeed hides the
uh the PA
and everything needs to be smaller than
into the C so that given this I can
recover the value over the integer
and the security holds because we
actually as I argued before ax plus b
which is a short label hides the PA
so now let's put it back together
on in this key extension we will get
we're sort of get ax plus b mod n to the
C and we recover it over the integers
this will allow me to decrypt this
homomorphically evaluated to the
ciphertext and now we're obtain the
output label CX plus the mod into the C
and suppose I have lwe how do we do that
it is very similar because in owe we
just have ciphertext which is take a
which is a vector now B is a matrix and
plus the value I want to encrypt
with a multiplier so that it doesn't I
can decrypt it correctly
linear homomorphism again works and I
have the same problem the key space is
in fact zq
and my message space is some zp which is
significantly smaller but again we're
going to pretend that the key space is
just over the integers and using the
same method we can work with the integer
key space
so
publishing from lwe difference for from
aik it's very similar after if you go
back to aik and try to kind of map
everything back it's essentially the
same scheme
but I think what we do is we have this
slightly more abstract idea and then
allow us to do also with DCR
and once you go to the zp computation
the mixed composition then it's
completely different because aik doesn't
really handle this conversation I don't
have time to tell you uh the technique
there these two are significantly more
complicated than the bounded integer
computation and the main problem is the
same and it's because I say that I have
a key space which is over the integer
and have message space which is over zp
where zp is exactly the computation ring
now I can never have the case right
given ax plus b the short label mod P to
recover ax plus b over Z that will just
never happen
and we have to use a very special
distributions of choosing those but
nonetheless we can actually do that but
in order to recover the integer value
from the mod P value we choose very very
specific distribution of A and B
I don't have the time to tell you that
but I think you've got the main idea
yeah
let me to go to the
last slide of some open questions
bonus now that we can do constant rate
arithmetic doubling
in my way that is somewhat concretely
efficient but not I'm not really
claiming concrete efficiency but there
is a ray of Hope
huh
compared to fhc and Abu schemes right I
believe that but then I'm very confident
but what stops Us in bounding the
integer computation if we want to think
big what about constant rate Boolean
doubling
who says we cannot do that
and
for the Mixed computation that I didn't
tell you about I think it has some
potential for practical applications but
the big decomposition Gadget is pretty
inefficient which I showed you which is
quadratic overhead with growing with the
key lines of the DCR
and one can think about specific
Boolean computations that we really care
about they're under many for example
threshold truncation comparison can we
design much much more efficient on
gadgets that allows us to handle
arithmetic computation in a natural way
and then an efficient Gadget that
handles these computations and that
would really allow us to basically deal
with like machine learning models
really of course more assumptions what's
so special about paler and lwe
absolutely
morphism is
approach represented beyond that
space and being able to decrypt it
doesn't have
but potentially it is more arithmetic
approach will also have used even in the
Boolean computation setting
just thank you
it's like um yes I guess like in uh
usually think about like security so
um I guess this is probably secure
against a malicious evaluator
um like is it secure against a malicious
partner is it
what
else has Governor seems not hopeful
because oh malicious gobbler no it's
certainly not and I don't even know that
we have any definition of doubling that
handles Mauritius gambler
because then you know you basically know
the Gambler outputs the gamble Circle
and the label functions right
now
makes sense for the in the context
discovering it says
in that case does that make sense yeah
yeah so so that's also
we didn't handle the kind and choose
whether you can do cut and choose for
this kind of goblin yeah
right right and also I would like that
um
well you can see it from our design
Paradigm basically you have to do this
uh
you have to do these key evaluation like
I think the basic addition the
multiplication dumpling is quite
efficient right you're just each
addition is one edition one ring Edition
and each multiplication is kind of a
constant overhead it's just a key
extension and if you look at the hour
keeps dancing in the Parlier
it's doing one party decryption for each
key extension proportional to the lens
of the output labels you want to get
yeah
you're just doing multiplication paying
the price of how long the output label
you want
yeah
if you think about what do I need to do
structure okay okay it's true yeah I
need to do additional multiplication
over the ring and I need to do this
decryption in the case of a Padilla then
there will be uh basically a modular
arithmetic mode and it's not the same
ring as the underlying ring in the case
of lwe is going to be modular arithmetic
over z q for Q that is bigger than my
underlying ring so it's still fairly
arithmetic
no question can we starting from if I
want to just gobble bring our
computation can I have a goblin which is
also just bring our computation that's a
full day Black Box in the online ring
and we know we cannot do that
how to Leverage The Sound property of
them up down the line
okay thank you